hello this is Ruth Whitaker and I'm
going to talk to you today about what's
new in forensic toxicology drugs and
standard-setting
we have a brief outline I'm going to
talk about some background and frame
words about what we're going to discuss
today they're talked about the various
ways that standards are set in forensic
toxicology and then I'm going to use
some case studies to you help you
understand what can happen when
standards aren't followed or shortcuts
are taken or even with the best
intentions when standards are followed
and how things can still go wrong
so forensic toxicology is a
multidisciplinary field involving the
detection interpretation of the presence
of drugs and other potentially toxic
compounds in bodily tissues and fluids
these analyses and interpretations are
conducted in a manner to be defensible
in court these include post-mortem
forensic toxicology which determines the
absence or presence of drugs and their
metabolites chemicals such as ethanol
and other volatile substances carbon
monoxide and other gases metals and
other toxic chemicals and poisons in
human fluids and tissues and evaluates
their role as a determinant or
contributory factor in the cause and
manner of death human performance
toxicology determines the absence or
presence of ethanol and other drugs and
chemicals and blood breath or other
appropriate specimens and evaluates
their role and modifying human
performance or behavior and then perfect
urine drug testing determines the
absence or presence of a usually limited
number of drugs and are metabolizing
urine to demonstrate prior use or abuse
of a drug
so I'm going to cover some definitions
here and so that that will frame what
we're going to talk about so a best
practice is a method technique or
process that has been generally accepted
as superior to any alternative because
it produces results that are superior to
those achieved by other means a minimum
practice standard is generally used to
improve the overall practice of a field
and bring all methods policies and
procedures up to a minimum level a
guideline is a formalization presented
by a clinical Society or government
agency as basis for voluntary adherence
as for acceptance of a work product
guidelines state the basis for an
acceptable product or process in general
guidelines use the words should when
stating what should be done a standard
by comparison is more rigidly defined
with less room for interpretation or
extrapolation into a situation the
standard exists only following the
process of testing and peer review and
in some fields this process can be very
formal and extensive to claim a certain
level of quality or achievement for a
particular practice one is required to
follow the standard and language use in
the standard is shall you shall do this
not you should do this
standard studying in forensic toxicology
has actually been around for a long time
and largely preceded the National
Academy of Sciences report on forensic
science in the in the United States in
1919 82 as code lab accredited their
first laboratory their first crime
laboratory and in 1986 the National
Laboratory certification program
developed standards for accreditation
for laboratories performing workplace
drug testing on the behalf of HHS or
Health and Human Services in 1991 soft
which is a society of forensic
toxicologist and AFS which is the
American Academy of Forensic Sciences
developed laboratory guidelines and the
first version in 1991 has been following
with new versions in 1995 and 2006 name
which is the National Association of
medical examiners had previously
accredited medical examiner offices
prior to 1995 but they did not do it on
a checklist it was a peer review at that
time and then their first checklist was
developed in 1995 American border
forensic toxicology which is a BSP
occurred as it accredited their first
medical examiner laboratory in 1997
in 1999 a NAB ad as cloud lab and took
all of their checklists and set
laboratories to the ISO standard 17025
finally in 2009 the National Academy of
Sciences report was issued on the state
of Forensic Sciences in the United
States and it was largely critical of
many practices of those toxicology to
get a passing grade and 20 in response
to that the swift toxic forms this is a
scientific working group in toxicology
and they began the first work on setting
standards for forensic toxicology
including guidelines and standards using
those shoulds and those shells
and in 2015 the forensic science
Standards Board and the organization of
scientific area tivities with font
founded it missed this is 25 forensic
disciplines suspicious specific groups
divided among five scientific area
committees
in 1918 20 sorry in 2018-2019 the
Academy standards aboard a standard
developing organization published to
toxicology standards and there's
actually nine further in line and in
June of 2019 the OSAC approved the first
of the toxicology standards that are
going through that process
workplace drug testing has a long
history of setting standards President
Ronald Reagan established the federal
workplace drug testing program in the
1980s and currently 117 federal agencies
are covered by the urine mandatory
guidelines in accordance with executive
order 1g5 for this executive order
currently covers approximately 2.2
million executive branch employees and
job applicants and these employees are
subject to annual testing or random
testing and are all subject to
reasonable suspicion testing for
suspected drug use the Department of
Transportation also utilizes the urine
mandatory guidelines in its regulatory
testing program requiring testing of
over 10 million safety-sensitive
employees and applicants in VOT
regulated transportation related
industries nationally particular
regulatory commission also uses
laboratories that are accredited by
these guidelines to test an additional 2
million employees and applicants in this
part get not regulated non regulated
sectors 20 to 50 million Americans are
tested as applicants or employees using
some aspects of the other mandatory
guidelines as such such 6 million plus
specimens are tested each year under the
national laboratory certification
program
this program provides comprehensive
laboratory quality assurance and
guidelines in order to ensure the
accuracy and dependability of employee
drug testing program it includes
verification of laboratory procedures
inspections and audits 10% of all non
negative specimens that are tested each
year by the accredited laboratories are
audited it includes proficiency testing
including all analytes tested under the
mandatory guidelines and including
common interference and simulation of
special issues this is considered the
gold standard in urine forensic urine
drug testing many aspects as the
mandatory guidelines are incorporated
into checklists and standards about
today for other forensic toxicology
testing purposes
however our not got it you just don't
set them and go there is a review
process that occurs on an annual
semiannual or a five-year basis
depending upon the standards and the
forensic urine drug testing urine
mandatory guidelines over the years
changes to the standards includes
development of specimen validity testing
to overcome and in response to a
plethora of products designed to thwart
the drug testing procedures allowing for
biomarker testing to validate the
specimen as biologically produced urine
rather than synthetic urine and the new
standards allowing for alternate initial
testing technology as many adulterous
disrupt immunoassays used for initial
testing
the American Board of forensic
toxicology adept objectives of the
accreditation program are to establish
enhance and maintain standards of
qualifications of the glabra choice that
practice post-mortem press across
pathology
marking and performance toxicology they
accredit these qualified laboratories to
comply with the requirements of the
board in this way the board aims to
establish the practical and equitable
system of readily identifying
laboratories that have demonstrated the
requisite qualifications and competence
in forensic toxicology the accreditation
based upon compliance with professional
standards as assessed by peer review and
a checklist
again it's a continually continually
evolving checklist analytical methods in
to 2014 were required to determine
ethanol using a two column GC method or
alternate method equivalent or greater
forensic strength that would include
mass spectrometry and then the newest
checklist is under construction in 2019
right now but why why would we want to
do that this is an example of a two
column method as you can see here
methanol ethanol and other volatile
elite in a certain order on the first
column but on the second column
the elites in a different order so you
have a switching of ethanol and acetone
in the second column that's important
because there are other volatile as you
can see here this is a taste example
where there appears to be a peak for
ethanol but in actuality on the second
column you can see that peak is moved
and it doesn't confirm for ethanol and
that's actually ethyl chloride a
commonly abused volatile
the organization of scientific area
activities as I mentioned before is a
group of friends like practitioners and
other individuals including universities
researchers consumer manufacturers and
and their 25 discipline-specific groups
among five scientific area committees
the toxicology group is part of the
chemistry instrumental analysis group
the toxicology group subcommittee is
focused on foundational documents to
improve the practice of forensic
toxicology and assure minimum policies
and practices are in place for example
the standard for the analytical scope
and sensitivity for forensic toxicology
and drug facilitated crime has been
developed to ensure laboratories are
using appropriate cut-offs and testing
schemes for those cases which are quite
different than testing required for
diagnosis of drug overdose deaths in
that way it ensures laboratories that
are that are handling multiple different
types of cases are treating them
differently as such and appropriately
importantly there will be a standard for
education and training in forensic
toxicology practitioners and as we'll
see you later just having a standard for
how to do something is no substitute for
properly trained and certified personnel
National Association of medical
examiners provides leadership and
advocacy for best practice and
excellence in forensic pathology and
death investigation
their checklist has a number of items
that are applicable to forensic
toxicology these included is peripheral
blood rather than central Valenti's for
toxicological testing whenever possible
is a sign of collection of the blood
used for toxicology recorded and also
reminding practitioners that toxicology
by itself should not be used as a
substitute for forensic autopsy or a
substitute for a careful search of a
death seeing for health and safety
hazards and when the toxicology is
requested the pathologist is required to
make the toxicologists aware of the
circumstances surrounding the death and
any medications which may have been
taken into by the decedent that's really
important and we're going to use some
case studies here to show so one of the
things that's really complicated about
post-mortem forensic toxicology are
these things called three analytical
challenges that means before the
specimen actually gets to the laboratory
things happen to the specimens that can
cause problems with interpretation of
the results to come out of the
laboratory in general the specimens
collected at autopsy are no different
than any other specimens although they
may be it they may have deteriorated
somewhat but the part the process is
still the same for analysis and
reporting of concentrations it's been
interpretation that you have to worry
about
so one of the key articles on this
process is called the pre a melodica pre
analytic aspects in post mortem
toxicology you can see that reference
here but though these are things that
are brought up in this article are what
I'm going to talk about in the next
sheet case studies these include sample
integrity post mortem alcohol formation
post-mortem redistributions bite
dependent for diffusion trauma artifacts
and medical artifacts who's next
in medical artifacts the two key things
in the name checklist are when
toxicology is requested is the
toxicologists made aware of
circumstances surrounding the death any
medications which may have been taken by
the decedent and is a complete
investigation done by the corner or
medical examiner here's the case where
that actually didn't happen so this was
big in the news in this area of the
country in which this young man died and
so there was an erectile of deception
drug found in the toxicology
unexpectedly in this young man after he
died he's only 16 years old he's at a
house party he's drinking and at autopsy
they find aspiration of the stomach
contents the effect of pretty low
ethanol value and they also find
papaverine which is a erectile
dysfunction drug the coroner and
assigned the cause of death as a 62 -
aspiration and other significant
conditions of ethanol and papaverine 'is
the opinion exhibited by the corner so
there's unknown whether the drug was
being used recreationally or someone
flipped it to him in a drink well this
was very hard on the family the did not
have any of this drug in the home
environment if they then feel like there
was some flat foul play in their son's
death and it and it pressured the
district attorney and Sheriff's Office
you pursue looking into this desk some
more
so later on it was found out that the
PAP averin was actually administered
during tissue retrieval so there was
some organization after this death and
so the coroner was forced to reevaluate
the situation and call the cause of
death undetermined and with other
significant condition of ethanol ease
and give a likely explanation
explanation of asphyxia and get rid of
the mention of the papyrus that wasn't
even administered until after death
another example of not telling to talk
to colleges what you're what you're
looking for and how that can affect what
you find in the toxicology results it's
just a reminder that there's no such
thing as a complete drug screen or a
complete lexicology test hi
psychologists are really dependent upon
the universe the the information that is
presented to them and it really is the
key of garbage in garbage out now this
is an old drug I'm going to talk about
next but it's this image but it's a
really good example of what can happen
and why you really need to keep those
lines of communication open with the
toxicologist so oxy warfarin was a new
drug that had been approved by the Food
and Drug Administration for individuals
with severe pain but as usual opioids
that are new on the market become a
target for abuse and and diversion so
this is a young man that died in North
Carolina after taking oxymorphone that
he got from a friend and this this drug
started showing up in the medical
examiner cases in May of 2007 both of
these early cases were young individuals
who really had no good reason to be dead
and had a history of intravenous drug
abuse one had recent needle punctures
one had a history of snorting pink pills
and and that was all the information
that was provided to the toxicology
laboratory and all of the skater
toxicology screens were negative and it
wasn't until we received the concept
call on the first case and the medical
examiner was this has to be a drug
overdose why was all the toxicology
negative and then he proceeded to tell
us that there was an apana tablet found
on the table next to the decedent so
that would have been very useful
information to the toxicology
because at that time in 2007 oxymorphone
or apana was an actual special test
didn't come out in your regular
screening test and if nobody mentions it
then nobody tests for it and that's what
happened there and it can happen with
other more routine things other more
routine poises in this example of an
insufficient investigation this
information wasn't even passed on to the
pathologist and therefore was not passed
on to the toxicology laboratory this
individual had a history of suicide
attempts it was a suicide note on the
scene and a list of drugs was provided
to the toxicology laboratory but it was
all negative
suddenly pictures of the scene were
obtained from law enforcement and we
find that there's some preston which is
any phrase if curtis will cause of death
if you if you drink it but again it's a
special test it doesn't come out over
the regular screen and sufficiently rare
that laboratory cannot use the resources
to screen every case for this particular
poison
unlike the oxymorphone after it appeared
on the scene it was quickly added to the
regular screen so that it could be
picked up and it was a very common drug
that caused death in individuals and
that time frame
so another one that I want to talk about
is from the name standards is checklist
is peripheral blood rather than central
blood used for toxic all toxicology
testing whatever possible and then is
the site of collection of the blood used
for the toxicology recorded this can be
really important peripheral blood or
femoral blood is it really considered
the gold standard in postmodern forensic
toxicology but it can have some problems
here's an example of this post want to
leave distribution a good article for
review and for those that are more
interested but as you can see here I've
dried moves from areas of high
concentration after both the areas of
low concentration and so you can get
increases in drug concentration after
death and that can mess up the
interpretation of the concentration of
or the implication as the cause of
manner of death terminal aspiration is
actually also very fairly common in a
methadone study of 331 cases showed that
in nine point three percent of the cases
there was evidence of perimortem
aspiration and dying is stressful to the
body and this can happen at that time
problems can occur if there is intact
tablet in the stomach at the time that
this happens because and you can also
get gastric trapping the basic drugs in
the stomach contents but if you have an
intact tablet you can get five thousand
and ran two drugs delivered and in a
nice neat package to the lens and then
it will diffuse from there which will
drastically increase the concentration
of drugs in the central specimen so in
this case a 48 year old white female has
a history of ethanol abuse and
recreational drug abuse is a bottle of
30 van X which is empty and aspiration
of gastric contents
you can see here the subclavian blood
between the consider looking generally
considered a specimen that's the tool
pencil and peripheral so it would have
computations that are higher I mean that
are lower than central but higher than
peripheral and then you see the femoral
blood here when concentrations you can
also see how dramatically different
these concentrations are between these
two specimens one of the problems here
with aspiration is that the London ear
the subclavian vessel and if you take
specimens from there then you can get a
lot of diffusion of the drug from the
line and if subclavian blood is the only
specimen you cook you could be misled to
believe this is a suicide because these
concentrations are indicative of that in
the subclavian blood but they're
perfectly normal in the summer all blood
so that's like taking femoral blood is
very important however things can go
wrong with taking femoral blood or
peripheral blood and this is an example
of that this is a 14 year old white male
the mother had missing oxycodone tablets
the autopsy was largely unremarkable as
you would expect in a 14 year olds and
the femoral vessels specimen was taken
by taking by external stick now taking a
femoral vessels specimen of blood is
important and is considered the gold
standard however taking by external
stick is not so as you can see here the
oxycodone which is what the decedent was
suspected have have been taken is quite
high and the metabolite the oxymorphone
is low and this is what you would think
of as kind of a normal distribution in
the federal vessel however that are
practically equal to oxycodone in the
oxymorphone and in urine and you see a
normal distribution again it was clearly
something wrong with the femoral
specimen in this case and it's only
because we had these other specimens
that we were able to see this so the
conclusion from the thermal vessel best
thing could be that the decedent has
gotten a hold of not only oxycodone
but oxymorphone if a good investigation
had not been done as well so the
interpretation of this is is problematic
external stick thermal Bessel
collections can be very problematic as
well they can they can be contaminated
with fat it can be contaminated with
diffused fluid from muscle and or if if
you hit that if you hit that vein and
you haven't tied it off then you can
pull down blood for more central
location and that could also affect the
concentration of the drug so it takes it
from being a gold standard specimen to a
no good specimen the specimen itself had
a funny color to it it looked kind of
green and we originally thought that
maybe it was bile even though it was
labeled as thermal blood specimen and so
we did a bio acid analysis and you can
see there's a simple vessel bile acid
was much much higher than the aorta but
because there was a good investigation
and because we had other samples in this
case and the cause of death was
attributed just to the oxycodone because
he showed that the most likely that is
the most likely scenario that the
decedent had only taken oxycodone
this is a picture of the vessel showing
you how they really are all connected
and if you pull down hard enough you can
pull blood from a more central location
one of the things that can also cause
problems is are you really designating
where you got the specimen from so some
pathologists will say they got the
specimen from femoral when they really
got it from the iliofemoral area and
about fine for most things but some
things it could be a problem with in
this particular case we had a 51 year
old female her femoral blood pre Gavilan
was was what I like to call ginormous is
really really large and the yearning
concentration is also quite large but
the aorta blood concentration of the pre
Gavilan is normal and in the graph to
the left here you can see the pre
Gavilan distribution of the
concentration and you can see that
almost all cases in post mortem that
concentration is between five and nine
point seven and very very few or are
much much higher than that
so what's going on here well the
iliofemoral vessel is actually sitting
there in that cavity and right there and
the the bladder actually sits right on
top of it and this the autopsy is
delayed you can get diffusion of that
flat of drugs from the urine in the
bladder right into that vessel and you
can get really high concentrations that
occur from that situation
so again if we had not had that central
blood specimen and we might have been
led to believe that that was an overdose
and even an intentional overdose of the
gabilan
so
and this is an example of specimens
collected from a funeral home that again
the note from the name of accreditation
checklist so the toxicology by itself
should not be used as a substitute for a
forensic autopsy or as a substitute for
a careful search of a death scene for
health and safety hazards and this is no
more true than in a sexual situation
this a woman had a history of some
natural disease and problems and heart
blood was submitted to the toxicology
laboratory from the funeral homes the
funeral home is the actual person that
has procured the specimen and submitted
it to the to the medical examiner
laboratory toxicology was requested and
that the family objected they said a fit
of money to do these analyses then we
want you to do an autopsy so this is
what happens
and the autopsy was performed and
femoral blood was collected but they
noticed that autopsy was there were four
needle punchers in the thoracic area and
that means that the individual is a
funeral home had a difficult time
collecting a specimen there also was
noted aspiration of the gastric contents
in at the autopsy you could see that
they have some pancreatitis and some
other minor natural disease findings and
the this specimen the thoracic conscious
specimen also didn't look right it was
kind of brown icky and so they set it
off for microscopy to look at it and
what what happened was they found there
was meat and other things so clearly
what happened at the funeral home was
that the individual prepared the sample
had difficulty getting the sample and
probably punctured the stomach and
that's what part of the sample actually
was
as you can see here the traffic cruncher
concentrations of these drugs including
ethanol are quite elevated and they look
like a acute massive ingestion of the
antidepressant amitriptyline but when
you look at the femoral blood specimen
there's no ethanol and one of the
reasons for that is that if you have
aspiration of gastric contents you can
aspirate some bacteria which will then
merrily go along their way and produce
some ethanol and there is no real
ethanol in this case all of that is a
post mortem or pre analytic artifact as
the amateur saline concentration and the
noir chilling Constitution are perfectly
normal in this case so this is a natural
death but has the only specimen that had
been submitted been the thoracic
puncture specimen it might have been led
the conclusion might have been quite
different and was had really bad
consequences for the family in this case
so I'm going to finish up here with
students and talk about you know what's
going on new and toxicology and what
what these new standards are going to do
to help us so no secret here that drug
deaths have increased dramatically in
the last ten years or so
um and exceeded motor vehicle crashes as
a cause of death quite some time ago in
that in that time frame this is largely
due to illicit medications and opioids
and new and novel psychoactive
substances including sinful analogs so
if you look at the top five drugs
poisoning by year way back in 2000 2001
heroin was in the top five and then it
dropped out it was mostly prescription
medications but then it came back again
the phenol that you see here in red is
all prescriptions as well so this is all
dirty sick and other prescribed
medications that were largely being
diverted and then abused
but the Sentinel and green here is
illicit we produce fentanyl and then the
blue is the fentanyl analogues
so the emerging threat report from the
Drug Enforcement Agency is is indicative
of how common this problem of fentanyl
and fentanyl analogs are largely in 2016
and 2017 there were a large number of
fentanyl analogues that were identified
along with fentanyl and substances that
were submitted for for analysis by the
DEA and the crime laboratories
in 2018 that changed a bit there were a
large number of identifications of
fentanyl but there was a lower amount of
identifications of related substances
and you can see that here in these
graphs and so in 2016 there's a large
number of eight and 877 or fentanyl and
142 of schrott offense and all then on
down the line you can see the other
analogues that were identified
and in 2017 facing a large amount of
Piran all sensible and other analogs and
other designer opioids are identify and
a fair number of them as well but in
2018 you can see it mostly goes to
fentanyl here a big number of fentanyl
and on the tube next most common items
before a and PP and the after till
fentanyl are actually produced for a MTP
is a precursor product that is used to
elicit lis manufacture personal and
official fentanyl is believed to be a
byproduct of the manufacturer of
fentanyl so these are separate things
that are identified in separate
submissions to the laboratory these are
things that are identified with the
fentanyl in the laboratory
in senator of 2018 the VA placed all
analogues of fentanyl not already
scheduled on to schedule one an animal
it can be defined as any substitution
along the main backbone of the fentanyl
better a lot better known as for a and P
T and you can see that here addition of
a three carbon carbonyl group makes
Sentinel removal of just one carbon from
that chain makes ask appealed Sentinel
commonly found as a byproduct of illicit
manufacturing addition of a fluorine in
the para position makes para flora
fentanyl substitution of a benzyl group
with a cyano group makes final fentanyl
and then addition of two carbon and
oxygen is a three carbon carbonyl group
makes Toronto fentanyl finally additions
and substitutions along the whole
backbone make al fentanyl which is
closely related to the really scary
molecule car fentanyl basically any new
compound is a substitution or addition
along the sacrum the result in immediate
schedule one placement the Osaka
toxicology subcommittee is working on a
standard for identification and forensic
toxicology freshly published on the
misled site in order for laboratories to
take a look at it and you know kind of
kick the tires on it see how it works in
their own laboratories
so it's based on a point system so
there's a minimum number of points
required for a positive identification
of an analyte there are points that are
greater based on the specificity of the
technique so a high resolution mass
spectrometer gives more points in a low
resolution mass spectrometer and also
stated is a standard is when known
isobaric and I thought Tomic sought to
Marek compounds exist they should be
evaluated during method validation well
with the plethora of specimens that have
been coming out and being found in
transit cases you're not going to know
right what is coming along and you're
not going to be able to evaluate all of
those things before before you put a
method online
so masters that new and novel
psychoactive substances epidemic has
presented many challenges for forensic
toxicology lab sperm in general on those
training there's an example the
standards can't really replace due
diligence and experience so down here on
the left is Sentinel and up on the top
right is para methodological Sentinel
and down on the bottom right is alpha
methyl acetate personal all these
molecules have the exact same molecular
weight and so using a high-res
instrument is not going to get you an
identification necessarily the para
methodological fentanyl will give you a
different structure when when you
analyze that molecule by either high res
path or Orbitrap or even LC ms/ms from
the Sentinel and the pair of methyl
acetate festival however with the
personal and the para más Alaska to
Sentinel both of those techniques even
though both are give more specificity
and you get more points in those
techniques in the system give you the
same product iron so the only way to
tell the difference between these two
molecules is to they use a different
technique GCMs which gives the same
major product iron of 245 but
differential ion of 146 for fentanyl and
164 para methyl acetate fentanyl and so
what happens here though is that you
can't expect standards to prevent all
errors in a lab civil case is positive
for the analog the para methyl official
Sentinel were identified as 1500 by
orbitrap I res m/s and confirmed by LC
ms/ms because the retention time and the
product iron ratio criteria were met
only on final review noticing that
Sentinel was not detected by a third
method for screening organic basis by
GCMs and the paramedical acid peel
Sentinel was detected prevented
reporting the wrong drug on a toxicology
report however labs doing targeted
analysis using immunoassay for sentinel
and LC ms/ms for confirmation testing so
Ferro central would be vulnerable to
reported cases positive professional
when it's really para mental hospital
Sentinel so clearly education training a
certification of personnel are integral
to the quality our forensic toxicology
process that's all I have today for you
I just wanted to tell you about what's
new and what's happening in standard
setting and improving and offensive
toxicology field thank you very much